könnte damit das große problem einer
möglichen mondstation gelöst werden
tatsächlich könnte die europäische
raumfahrtbehörde esa einen weg gefunden
haben wie man auf dem mond luft zum
atmen produzieren kann allerdings gibt
es noch eine hürde
pixum science fiction da gibt es
spannende science videos abonniert den
kanal und aktiviert die glocken dann
verpasst ihr nichts los geht's herzlich
willkommen die european space agency
kurz esa hat große pläne für den mond
sie will eine mondbasis bauen die immer
weiter wachsen soll und vom esa
kontrollzentrum in darmstadt aus
gesteuert und überwacht werden kann
sie soll nicht nur europäischen forscher
innen einen lebensraum auf dem mond
bieten sondern für alle nationen und
unternehmen offen stehen die ihren
anteil an der weltraumforschung leisten
wollen esa chef jan wörner spricht von
einem mond dorf neben wohnraum einer
strom- und wasserversorgung braucht
dieses dorf aber vor allem etwas ganz
substanzielles sauerstoff die frage wie
man auf dem mond an sauerstoff kommen
kann stellen sich experten schon lange
jetzt scheint es einen echten durchbruch
zu geben die lösung soll die sauerstoff
gewinnung aus mondstaub sein diesen
staub den sogenannten reguliert kann man
sogar von der erde aussehen er überzieht
unseren trabanten mit einer dicken
staubigen schicht ist grau extrem fein
und sehr schwer
die substanz die jetzt eine lösung für
die zukunft der raumfahrt sein könnte
hat ihr bisher vor allem schwierigkeiten
bereitet da es auf dem mond weder wind
noch regen gibt werden die feinen
partikel nicht geglättet der staub ist
deshalb also diese kleinen partikel
messerscharf wie glas und die partikel
sind etwa 50 mal feiner als ein
menschliches haar sie dringen durch
kleinste ritzen oder setzen sich auf
raumanzügen und geräten ab und gelangen
so ins innere von raumschiffen so kann
es zur fehlfunktion in schaltkreisen
kommen auch für unseren menschlichen
organismus ist der reguliert ein problem
denn er kann über monate in unseren
lungen bleiben alle zwölf raumfahrer die
bisher auf dem mond waren litten unter
dem sogenannten mondrausch nutzen der
für niesen und verstopfte nasen sorgt
wird der staub über einen längeren
zeitraum ein grab mit können sogar
lungen und gehirnzellen zerstört werden
bislang ist aber noch nicht vollständig
geklärt wie giftig der mond stoff für
menschen ist in einem trainings areal in
der nähe von köln sollen demnächst
astronautinnen mit künstlichem mondstaub
konfrontiert werden
mehr darüber herauszufinden und die
raumfahrer innen auf die staubige
herausforderung vorzubereiten wie soll
dieser grauen staub astronautinnen nun
beim atmen helfen die zusammensetzung
des regulierers macht ihnen für dieses
vorhaben so wertvoll
neben oxiden wie silizium kalzium
magnesium und eisen enthält er auch
einen sauerstoffanteil der bei
durchschnittlich achtung 43 prozent
liegt dieser könnte aus dem staub
gewonnen und als atemluft genutzt werden
das testet die esa gerade in einer
versuchsanlage im europäischen
weltraumforschungsinstitut zentrum in
noordwijk in den niederlanden um den
sauerstoff möglichst effizient zu
extrahieren wird der feine reguliert mit
geschmolzenem calciumchlorid einem salz
gemischt und auf 950 grad celsius
erhitzt dadurch schmilzt das salz der
reguliert aber nicht dann leitet man
strom durch die schmelze und der
sauerstoff löst sich aus der verbindung
und wandert durch das salz bis er von
einer anode also einer positiv geladenen
elektrode aufgefangen wird an der
kathode hingegen sammeln sich die
metalle die im regolith gebunden sind
der so aufgefangene sauerstoff kann
gespeichert und zum atmen oder zur
treibstoffproduktion für raketen
eingesetzt werden vom mondstaub bleibt
nur noch eine krümelige mixtur aus den
verschiedenen metallen die man weiter
verarbeiten könnte sie könnten zum
beispiel als werkstoffe für den aufbau
und die wartung einer mondstation zum
einsatz kommen ziemlich praktisch der
baustoffe auf dem mond bekanntlich sehr
begrenzt sind in einem vergleichsweise
kleinen umfang funktioniert dieser
prozess bereits er war übrigens
ursprünglich gar nicht zur sauerstoff
gewinnung gedacht sondern um an seltene
metalle zu gelangen
die in der erde zum teil nur als spuren
vorkommen die britische firma matches
hatte den prozess entwickelt und dabei
die extraktion von gasen entdeckt die
eigentlich nur ein nebeneffekt war die
esa hat den prozess übernommen und will
ihn in den kommenden monaten weiter
optimieren die benötigte
betriebstemperatur soll weiter reduziert
werden da die erhitzung noch eine große
menge elektrischer energie verbraucht
die auf dem mond nunmal mangelware ist
oder man müsste halt riesige
solarkraftwerke bauen das ziel ist die
konstruktion einer testanlage die ohne
viel menschlichen einsatz auf dem mond
funktionieren kann dann könnte man eine
art sauerstoff fabrik auf dem mond bauen
die schon vor der errichtung einer
mondstation ein vorrat an atemluft
anlegen kann wobei wir auf dem mond
wahrscheinlich eher höhlenmenschen
werden
mondstation eishöhlen auf dem mond
entdeckt anklicken anschauen und krieg
zum science fiction abonnieren es lohnt
sich bis dann bleibt dran